bonjour à tous il n'est pas toujours
évident quand on fait des vidéos sur
youtube de trouver le bon titre qui va
accrocher qui va déclencher l'action qui
permettra aussi de se référencer dans
cette vidéo je vous donnais les bonnes
astuces et les bonnes pratiques pour
écrire un titre aux petits oignons
de plus en plus de chaînes voit le jour
et il est extrêmement difficile de
réussir sur youtube je partage avec vous
toutes les astuces et même meilleures
techniques pour gagner des vues des
abonnés et enfin aussi à sur youtube
inscrivez-vous à ma chaîne est activé la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune vidéo
si vous voulez aller plus loin pour
réussir sur youtube cliquez sur le lien
pour rejoindre la communauté avant de
commencer je vous posais la question du
jour comment est-ce que vous choisissez
vos titres
est-ce que vous choisissez un petit peu
vos titres par hasard est ce que c'est
selon une idée qui vous viendra la tête
comment est-ce que vous fonctionnez ce
qu'il ya une stratégie ou est-ce que
c'est du feeling meet et maintenant
commentaires qu'on puisse regarder sans
en discuter et puis voir au final si
vous appliquez la bonne méthode créer un
bon titre sur youtube n'est pas toujours
chose facile
il doit répondre à deux objectifs
principaux le premier c'est de
référencer votre vidéo pour pouvoir être
prouvée dans les résultats de recherche
ou alors d'être suggéré sur la barre
latérale ou sur la page d'accueil
il doit aussi susciter l envie de
cliquer quand quelques envois vos titres
on doit se dire c'est ce qu'on ne veut
voir je clique dessus et jori exactement
le résultat que je recherche
vos titres doit être actionnable
référent sable et efficace sauf que
faire un titre qui va vous permettre
d'avoir des résultats et ça se fait pas
trop au hasard il ya une certaine
méthode à utiliser et à respecter pour
avoir des résultats durables qui vous
permettront d'avoir des vues sur le long
terme
le tout premier point à prendre en
considération c'est la recherche de mots
clés
vous souhaitez faire une vidéo vous avez
l'idée de vidéos d'accord mais si cette
vidéo ne répond pas à une problématique
ou si elle ne correspond pas à une
recherche de mots clés
vous allez très très très peu de chances
d'être découvert d'avoir des vues i les
convertir en abonnés pour faire votre
recherche de mots clés
je vous invite à aller voir cette vidéo
que j'ai déjà réalisé
c'est extrêmement simple de trouver les
bons mots clés tu veux permettront
d'avoir des résultats
votre titre doit être actionnable dire
que quand quelqu'un va tomber sur votre
vidéo au hasard n'ayant fait une
recherche ou alors qu'elle lui ait
suggéré en lisant titre on doit se dire
je veux cliquer ça m'intéresse
ça doit répondre à la problématique ou
alors vous devez vraiment intrigué
apporter un petit quelque chose qui
donne envie de cliquer alors on parle
pas forcément de ce qu'on appelle le put
un clic le put un clic c'est-à-dire
avoir un titre qui est extrêmement
incitatif mais par contre vous avez
derrière un résultat qui n'est pas du
tout là et la vidéo est décevante
ça ça ne marche pas c'est très mauvais
pour le référencement et puis d'ailleurs
pour votre image de marque dans ce qu'il
faut c'est effectivement que votre titre
intrigue qu'il incite au clic mais
qu'après dans la vidéo vous apportiez
des vrais résultats est en tout cas que
ça corresponde vraiment au titre de
votre vidéo votre type de donc donné le
bénéfice pour la personne qui a envie de
cliquer qu'est-ce qu'il va avoir comme
bénéfices à regarder cette vidéo est ce
que vous répondez une problématique
particulière
ou alors est-ce que vous allez parler
d'un sujet qui intéresse tout
particulièrement la personne qui fait
les recherches ne perdez jamais vu que
youtube est le deuxième moteur de
recherche au monde après google youtube
appartient à google par alphabètes qui
est la grande maison mère qui chapote
google youtube et toutes les activités
du groupe
il est donc super important de faire des
titres référents sable quand vous
écrivez votre titre vous devez trouver
la bonne expression clé le bon boucler
ça je vous le dis juste avant mais vous
devez rédiger d'une certaine manière
imaginant quelqu'un qui recherche chose
de très précis comment perdre du poids
là à ce moment là il est très clair que
le mot clé l'expression clé va être
comment perdre du poids votre titre veut
donc être comment perdre du poids
d'autant plus que youtube référence vos
vidéos par pertinence et les propose par
pertinence si quelqu'un t'a comment
perdre du poids et que vous votre titre
et comment perdre du poids vous avez
énormément de chances d'apparaître en
haut des résultats de recherche
après attention la concurrence s'il ya
une vraie grande concurrence il faut
plutôt que vous privilégiez des
expressions longue comme comment perdre
du poids rapidement mais ça je vous
l'expliquais dans ma vidéo qui parle des
mots clés imaginons par exemple que vous
voulez travailler le mot-clé maigrir
vite mais aussi l'expression comment
perdre du poids à ce moment-là écrivez
votre titre de la manière suivante
maigrir vite
tirer comment perdre du poids n'oubliez
pas bien sûr de le mettre également dans
la description pour le référencement
mais ça je vous l'expliqué aussi dans la
vidéo précédente sur la recherche de
mots clés avec ce type de titres youtube
vous référencer sur deux expressions
clés la première partie est la deuxième
partie c'est donc deux expressions
différentes qui vous permettront d'être
mieux référencés dans les restos de
recherche et permettre à votre vidéo
d'augmenter en vue
si votre contenu répond à la
problématique est que votre chaîne est
cohérent par rapport à d'autres niches
vos vues vous ferons partir en abonnés
et votre chaîne va croître très
rapidement il ya un autre point à
prendre en considération ce sont les
miniatures votre titre travaille en
tandem travail en duo avec vos miniature
vous pouvez pas avoir un super titre qui
incite à l'action avec vraiment un
travail fait sur le référencement qui va
être énorme et avoir une miniature qui
est tout pourri à côté
la plupart des gens quand ils regardent
le doigt de recherche regarde avant tout
les miniatures alors il s'agit pas
entrave aux miniatures de reprendre
exactement le contenu de votre titre
parce que ça ne sert à rien mais de
mettre les quelques mots clés qui vont
tout de suite permettre de comprendre de
quoi parle votre vidéo dites vous bien
que si quelqu'un regarde les miniatures
et que la vôtre interpelle il ya une
grande probabilité qu'ils avaient
ensuite regardé le type de votre vidéo
on clique et faut toujours avoir ça en
tête
un titre et une miniature doivent être
créé ensemble est cohérent ensemble je
vous invite d'ailleurs à les voir ma
vidéo pour savoir comment faire de
belles signatures et des miniatures que
permettront d'augmenter votre taux de
clics sur youtube pour trouver des idées
de titre c'est pas extrêmement compliqué
la première chose à faire si vous êtes
dans une niche et que vous avez
identifié des concurrents c'est tout
simplement d'aller voir ce que font
aller voir les concurrents qui
réussissent ceux qui ont du succès avec
des vidéos qui référencent vous allez
tout de suite comprendre la bonne
méthode ce que recherchent les gens et
sur quoi est ce qu'ils sont référencés
un point qui est important
j'ai déjà dit dans une précédente vidéo
mais je le redis encore si vous prenez
par exemple une chaîne qui va parler de
perte de poids ou n'importe quel autre
thématique ça fonctionne exactement
pareil pour toutes les thématiques si le
compteur de vue d'une vidéo est beaucoup
plus grand que le compteur de ses
abonnés ça veut dire que sa vidéo ses
références et ça veut dire que sa
vignette est bonne et cliquable
actionnable et que le titre l'est tout
autant et lui permet d'être référencés
inspirez-vous deux parce qu'il ya beau
beaucoup de choses à apprendre des
concurrents fait aussi les recherches
dans la barre de recherche de youtube
tapez le début d'autres expressions clés
et vous verrez ça vous sortira des mots
clés à travailler ça vous aidera
vraiment à trouver un titre pertinent je
voulais dit mais je vous redis encore
youtube référence par pertinence
ce qui fait que si votre type correspond
exactement à l'expression cherchez vous
allez vous positionner les petites
astuces qui est vraiment sympa si par
exemple vous avez un mot clé imaginons
ce soit perdre du poids très basique
vous n'avez pas identifier le type de
question que les spectateurs vont poser
vous taper dans la barre de recherche de
youtube underscore perdre du poids ou
alors perdre du poids et après un an de
leur score ça vous proposera des
expressions clés à travailler pour vos
titres et vous allez voir c'est très
pratique c'est une astuce qui marche
très très bien
le plus important ce joli pour est
référent cessé de cumuler du temps de
visionnage il faut vraiment que vos
vidéos soient intéressants que les gens
et regardez là quasiment jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout ça serait l'idéal mais
moins que vous avez vraiment un temps de
visionnage qui se cumulent pour votre
vidéo gagne en popularité que votre
vidéo puisse se référencer et que votre
chaîne soit découverte
d'ailleurs il ya un outil qu'est
vraiment sympa pour se référencer ça
s'appelle tu me dis alors c'est un outil
qui est en anglais mais vous allez voir
que c'est pas très compliqué vous tapez
un mot clé de danse ça va vous proposer
des expressions clés ça va vous montrer
quels sont les concurrents qui sont
positionnées ça vous donnera le volume
de recherches sont donc les que vous
avez tapé et ça vous permettra également
de savoir s'il ya une forte concurrence
et si vous avez une chance de vous
positionner je vous invite à cliquer sur
le lien pour aller faire tu me dis moi
j'utilise c'est un super outil et ça
permet vraiment de progresser surtout de
comprendre comment marche le
référencement sur youtube ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre sur youtube si vous avez
vraiment de grandes familles de vidéo
qui existe
la première famille sont des vidéos qui
répondent à des questions précises
comment perdre du poids comment mieux
s'alimenter comment ci commença
si votre contenu est plutôt de ce côté
là faut vraiment vous travaillez les
expressions clés qui vont être
recherchées et qui vous permettront
d'être positionné d'être découvert
d'avoir des vues de les convertir en
abonnés de faire augmenter votre chaîne
voice est toujours un petit peu là la
même mécanique et une deuxième mode
grande famille qui est un peu plus
délicate à travailler mais qui se fait
tout aussi bien se sont par exemple les
contenus je dirais humoristique les
sketches les blogs
là par contre il ya quand même des
petites choses intéressantes à
travailler kevin est un super exemple
pour ça faut par exemple trop
et la thématique forte le point fort
dans votre blog c'est par exemple vous
réalisez un blog et vous êtes parti dans
un parc d'attraction il y à de très très
fortes chances que le mot clé pas
d'infraction soient recherchés et qu'ils
aient des recherches additionnelles par
rapport à ça trouver une thématique pour
votre vidéo soit du blog ce soit un
sketch qui vous permettront d'être
référencés et une fois de plus regarder
ce que font les concurrents ça vous
aidera énormément utilisé tu me dis
faites les recherches dans votre barre
youtube dans votre barre de recherche
youtube et vous verrez vous allez
trouver les bonnes expressions clés pour
vous référencer si vous voulez aller
plus loin pour réussir sur youtube
si malgré mes conseils vous avez du mal
à comprendre comment trouver les bonnes
expressions clés commente référence sur
youtube je vous invite à la joie de la
polio des tipis vous avez bien la
description vous allez voir on a
vraiment travaillé ensemble pour vous
faire réussir sur youtube
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo mais
témoin tous vos commentaires parlez-moi
de vos problématiques de vos thématiques
mais tim thomas et je regarderai je me
ferais un plaisir d'y répondre
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
si vous voulez savoir comment faire
évoluer votre chaîne youtube y aura de
plus en plus de vidéos comme celle ci
pour vous aider à faire croître votre
audience à avoir des vues et les
convertir en abonnés quant à moi je vous
dis à très bientôt
salut
[Musique]